Vice President Mike Pence says that he
will go to Texas tomorrow to meet the
victims of that shooting President Trump
arrived in South Korea overnight after a
two-day visit to Japan he defended
existing gun laws at a news conference
in Seoul early this morning president
also said a lot of progress is happening
on North Korea and he urged that country
to quote make a deal major Garrett is
traveling with the president in Asia and
he's with us now from Seoul major good
morning South Korea fears war in ways it
hasn't for decades North Korea's
ballistic and nuclear missile tests are
the principal reason why not helping
matter as much president Trump's
summertime rhetoric about raining fire
and fury down on the north and later
telling his Secretary of State that the
very idea of direct talks with the north
was a waste of time but today in this
gleaming capital city roughly 35 miles
south of the Demilitarized Zone the
president's approach suddenly made room
for diplomacy South Korea greeted
president Trump with pageantry as his
motorcade made the slow approach to a
flag waving crowd and South Korean
president moon jae-in a newly elected
center-left leader who rolled out the
red carpet in hopes of softening mr.
Trump's Twitter criticism of moon's
outreach to North Korea as appeasement
at Camp Humphreys the joint us-south
Korean military base near Seoul the
president appeared to soften his
rhetoric with North Korea at a press
conference with moon the president did
not rule out direct talks it makes sense
for North Korea to come to the table and
to make a deal that's good for the
people of North Korea and the people of
the world and then the president noted
the presence of three US aircraft
carrier groups and a nuclear submarine
in the region we have unparalleled
strength there has never been strength
like it we hope to god we never have to
use not far away protests for and
against the American president some in
South Korea fear mr. Trump will bring
conflict
we denied Trump's coming here and we
deny Trump's bad words to provoke word
the pro-trump faction said North Korea
must be dealt with more aggressively
Goodell said I'm done many people this
man said wish that President Trump
attacks kim jeong-hoon North Korea fears
regime changes therefore obsessed with
u.s. and South Korean military maneuvers
the very large naval presence of the
United States in the region likely to
overshadow the president's efforts to
defuse the current situation and after a
day of mixed signals Charlie the burden
will be on the president to outline a
way forward with the north in his speech
tomorrow to the South Korean National
Assembly major garden Seoul major thank
you